uh michael thomas and the new orleans
saints the unexpected deactivation of
thomas for monday night's game because
of a fight with a teammate jeff duncan
athletic had a great story that goes
down the rabbit hole on the issues that
the saints have had with michael thomas
he's a very intense guy and that
intensity at times has caused him to be
difficult whether it's interactions with
trainers interactions with others on the
team just boorish behavior that
reportedly required sean payton at some
point to have a one-on-one with michael
thomas during training camp they thought
they were past all of that he gets into
a fight with cj gardner-johnson a safety
on the team they shut him down for
monday night's game and there was always
a weird vibe to this like what did they
really do why did they do it he had the
ankle problem he was limited in practice
all week just like he was limited all
week the week before and he didn't play
in the week four contest
what was really going on here and there
were multiple reports from people who
cover the team that it was a one-game
suspension for conduct detrimental to
the club and that was the centerpiece
that was the primary presumption from
which everything jeff duncan wrote
yesterday flowed
i got my hands on the letter
the saints didn't suspend michael thomas
which is just bizarre but you know if
you suspend him you pick a fight over
nearly 28 million in remaining
guaranteed money that by the language of
his contract automatically would avoid
it if he would have been suspended for
conduct detriment of the team he was
fined the amount of a game check
not suspended he was fined for conduct
detriment on the team because of the
fight
but
what it means is
you're not going to have this collateral
fight now
with 28 million hanging in the balance
and you're not potentially gonna lose
michael thomas you know if you push a
guy like michael thomas too far sharing
what happens at some point he says i
want out and i think that's the dance
the saints are trying to do you have to
get him
under control
but if you push him too hard
we've seen other players
in the nfl and in other sports they
decide they're done with a team and you
can't reel that back in you can try all
you want but if that player is
determined to get out you're going to
have to trade him and i think that's why
the saints may be trying to walk this
line of
we're we're being tough with thomas but
at the same time we're not being as
tough as we're making everyone think we
were being with thomas
and it's funny mike because he wasn't
suspended he was fine but yet he didn't
play in the game and that had nothing to
do with the injury so basically
he was suspended without being suspended
and they are trying to walk that line
and they are trying to show toughness he
did need to be suspended not play in the
game which he was but at the same time
they're not taking his money away and
trying to
say okay now
you know let's you can be a good player
on this team for us still and like you
said not getting him to the point where
he wants to go elsewhere he has a
difficult reputation uh as was written
about in the athletic story by by duncan
and the the saints are going to have to
put up with that now for however much
longer he plays however much longer he's
on their team and they hope it's for a
really long time because we saw last
year what he can do
all time record 149 catches and you've
seen how much this year that drew brees
misses those catches they want him back
they want him back this week and they
want him to play and play well
yeah and surely he's frustrated by the
injury i get it but at a certain point
if your behavior is unacceptable they
are going to take action and this fine
was the first shot across the bow at
thomas and if he doesn't shape up it's
not going to be 58 000 his base salary
is only a million dollars so it's not
like it's a gigantic number he had a
restructuring of his contract in the
off-season that dramatically shrunk
the salary for this year would have been
a huge hit but it's just a million
dollar salary 58 000 game check and uh
you know we'll see we'll see if he
learns from it and if they have to be
more aggressive with him moving forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports